Alright, so this is going to be an update to the YouTube channel because there's a
lot of people freaking out thinking I'm missing or gone.
I'm on vacation folks, but I took the opportunity to sit down here this morning with you and
try to hopefully make a mile marker on the equity on this live account.
I'm going to try to hit 50,000.
So I'm watching this potentially make a fair value gap.
I want to see that swing high broken.
I'll see if we get that here.
And again, this account is really meant to show like averaging like 20% a month.
I get questions all the time like, you know, what do I think a student that has gone through
all the teachings have worked out a model, you know, what could they recently expect
to see and what could be done without really pushing the envelope?
And this is kind of like my answer to that.
Also to kind of like remind everybody, I'm not just finding cherry pick trades in a camp.
I can trade with live funds too.
All right, so we're about to break that swing high.
If it does, that'll be bullish market structure.
I'm thinking we can trade back to on the daily chart back to like 14,000, but that's a little
bit of a stretch so far intraday.
Okay, we have the market structure bullish now.
So there's a fair value gap.
I'll highlight that.
I'll go into the chart here.
I'm watching this candle, see how it closes because that will complete our imbalance.
You can see that right there.
Okay, give me another.
Right there.
That's the low end of the fair value gap.
This thing's always tricky.
All right, so now we have to close that candle.
So now I can, I'm a little off on that because I'm clumsy with thinkorswim.
Change the color here so you can see a little bit better.
Now it's technically the open, so it's a little bit of volatility that comes in here.
I can overshoot that low.
I don't care if it does.
If it goes back up into the fair value gap, I will buy it.
Okay, now when you're entering on like the opening, like 930 equities opening, you could
take a long entry here, but you don't know how far it's going to whip below that low
and you could be wrong and painfully wrong.
So what I'm watching is, does it want to go below that short-term low that's already
created moments ago, which would be outside and below the fair value gap, and it does
not negate the fair value gap because I'm using narrative.
Narrative is that I expect people to look at that and say, okay, it's going to go up
and they're already trying to buy right now, but their stop loss is going to be below that
swing low.
So sell stops are resting at 13,614.
They just took those now.
Now this is a high-risk entry long there, but I'm watching price now entering that same
fair value gap.
So one more time to see if it wants to poke a little bit lower, and again, my daily bias
is bullish, so I'm looking for higher prices.
So I'm going to go and aim for the 80 level.
That'll give me a nice figure to run to $50,000 on equity.
I do believe it's going to go higher, but I'm on vacation, so I want to kind of like
let me take this long entry, and there you go.
All right, so now I'm watching price, and I want to see it expand up.
Now because it's the opening, and I don't know where if we whip below that low, I'll
give it a chance to go below it just by a little bit, and I'll close it at market.
Generally I like to trade with a stop loss, but if I'm trading to open like this, stops
can be taken really, really easily, and then reverse, and then never give you a chance
to be in it.
So I'm allowing myself a little bit of flexibility.
I'm not trying to encourage you to trade without a stop loss.
I'm right here ready to click and close it if it trades below it, and I want to see it
expand up.
Now I want to see an energetic run above the swing high that was formed just to the left
of where we are right now.
There is a fair value gap at the 680 level, and it's above equilibrium, so it would be
a premium market, so that's why I'm going to be targeting the 80 level, plus it's around
50 handles, so that gives me about $1,000 or more.
All right, so now, right now, at this moment, I want to see it expand aggressively, not
dilly dally around.
I want to see it really try to spread its wings and take off and start moving.
There's a small little fair value gap in the last three candles up.
I don't think it needs to fill that in or even revisit it, but if it were to, I wouldn't
expect price to be supported by that.
So in other words, not going below the 630 level.
Now at this moment, I could put the stop-loss one at my entry, and if it takes me out, then
would basically move to the sidelines and wouldn't take any more trades today because
it's FOMC, and FOMC, you can trade in the morning, but you've got to be done early.
If you're trading equities, it's important to be aware of the economic calendar because
we're probably going to have a lot of volatility later on today.
I still think they'll push it higher with that.
So here's my limit order.
I'm going to place it there, and we'll see if we can get this puppy to reach up there
and grab it.
I mean, I feel confident it's going to go way beyond that, but short little scalp, very
little drawdown, about three handles of drawdown, if that, from the entry or the candle I entered
on, I'll say it that way, the low from my entry was only like three handles below.
I have to go watch the video and see what the actual drawdown was from the point of
entry.
I'm not sure if I had any.
If I did, then that's what it was limited to, 60 bucks or so.
Not bad if you're trying to make $1,000.
I had a small little scalp early in the morning.
All right, and now this is where neophyte traders or newbies, they get nervous.
Hit the wrong thing here.
I always think I'm on the other platform, so I use TradeStation, and I use TradingView,
and it's different settings, different things you can look for.
All right, so there's my fill on the limit order.
Rounding out the day and the month of March.
I will not be taking any more trades this month.
So $1,255 on two trades, about $15 or so in commissions, so take that off of there.
That will be the net for the day.
I'll take you over to the monitor tab here.
After I scrunch this up, I'll show you the run on the price.
Now, I think it's going to go higher, but here's the monitor tab showing the actual
trades today, and you can see the profit and loss since I started this account and the
commissions, which are high because I did a lot of latency tests and I've done a lot
of things that would kind of like mimic what a new trader would do once they get into live
fund trading.